what about the jews what's that what
about the jews
jesus christ
well
well well
man oh man i've never seen a race war
that quick holy [ __ ]
that was wild
i didn't know we had palestine over here
on the right side
holy hell all right well this is getting
a little kooky what the hell is going on
in here
hopefully saying [ __ ] him not [ __ ] them
because look we need to keep this
weather all right don't [ __ ] with these
guys too much
[Applause]
geez louise sorry there
you face you really got uh
now you always hear about oh
anti-semitism it's around you're like
all right shut up you [ __ ]
you know and
then you see old uh
[ __ ] uh what's his name abu grave or
whatever the [ __ ] uh
arafat what's the guy's name i can't
keep up
um cool all right let's uh let's wrap
this thing up with a bow this is off the
rails here
okay
i've been doing comedy 15 years i've
never seen someone say
[ __ ] them
to an entire race of people
that was wild
all right
this guy's a [ __ ] psycho huh
man oh man we got nick cannon here i
think huh
i know i look like a jew but i'm not i'm
just saying all right all right cool
all right somebody gonna tase this guy
or what
what are you doing here
can i hit this guy with a chloroform or
some [ __ ] all right
you'll find me there's a guy with a
swastika on his neck yeah that'll be the
guy there you go all right
um
cool okay well this is uh we're gonna
we're gonna try to
land this plane i'm like captain sully
here you know
this guy's a [ __ ] seagull in my
engine and i'm like
[Music]
all right here we go
um
appreciate it very nice you know very
nice it feels a little make-a-wishy but
uh yeah
there you go